this is the finale look at this is
amazing this is it this is our office
are you nervous excited for this way are
we performing well no you're about to
change someone's life i know this is
insane that is true no one thing i know
is when i took like the job was offered
to me to become a judge on ken scott
town which was blown away why did you
put somebody in a headlock which one
let's me let's be let's be honest she
did that to you didn't she sure there's
the producers i did it too um but
anyways so i knew like the the potential
of changing hey guys
congratulations that's that's probably
stacy kay yeah yeah they're doing an
interview and we're doing a sound check
hey if you guys could just keep it down
we're trying to do an interview up here
okay thank you
we're good
all right very effective very effective
see she's in charge i mean
i hope you guys kept the the initial
thing remember remember what i told you
yeah she's like oh i'm not like that
now i'm whispering i don't
i'll have to go down there don't make me
take my earrings off anyway next
question
no when i got the job yes i knew that we
could like potentially change the
trajectory of someone's life and that to
me was not only an honor but just super
exciting to just be a little part of
their journey so tonight knowing that
we're going to really like find the one
or be part of finding one or we have
been really getting this group so maybe
we found the one oh maybe we're dead so
that's the question do you have a
feeling who's going to win or do you
want someone particular to win so here's
the thing you don't want to tell me who
it is but do you know he will oh no he
will oh you're going to talk
because i'm absolutely an unbiased judge
here's the thing i want for canada to
really feel like they have the power to
vote in the person who they think is the
best stacey k so it's like whatever is
you know i'm saying whatever they feel
whatever performance really moves them
uh about my golden buzzer stacy k that's
the one that they should vote on whoever
like anybody else
i don't know but you know i wouldn't i
would never put
my uh golden buzzer opinions on to the
rest of the country stacy
so clearly that was his goal because
he's been pushing his agenda on youtube
we do each have a bit of an affinity
towards our golden buzzer moments
because it was like that moment i
remember saying how like how will you
know your golden buzzer moment and he
said you'll just know you'll feel it and
it really was like that's how it felt so
stacey k um that was also that was
clearly um and so he's really rooting
because just i think he just wants to be
like i picked her yeah i think yeah uh
have you seen her she's also fantastic
by the way in the semi-finals yes right
but so are the other seven
honestly yes
it's been really tough this talent group
is so amazing and to be a little bit
like uh you guys decide canada you can
we can yeah
what is that feeling though sitting at
the judges table you're seeing this
talent come on stage and they're they
have that look and they want to just do
their best and they want their dreams to
come true and you're part of that so let
me let me give you something one of the
first acts that we saw like our first
time sitting in the judge's chair yeah
and they bring out all these little
girls like little seven and eight
remember the ballerina yeah i was like
how the hell do you want to say no what
am i supposed what am i supposed to do
with that that was like our first like
the first act that came out and i was
just like oh this is a setup this season
is like they want to see how we do yeah
like
absolutely so when you say like how is
it i think they did that on purpose
because they're like listen if they can
critique or like have an opinion on
these little beautiful girls that are
doing you know their their ballet then
they can do whatever so from that that
kind of set the tone for the rest of the
season and after that it was very easy
get them out of here like that was happy
which it works
you guys are light no listen listen you
guys were buzzer i use my buzzer
accordingly sparingly
because talent there was so much talent
there was that's the see that's the
right answer i kind of really realized
that but there was also really there was
really bad talent as well yeah there was
so you have no place on our stage yeah
there we go oh no oh now when is the
finale
for next year next season for season two
manifesting manifesting we'll see i'm
gonna listen next year my thing is gonna
be like a michael jackson gloves oh yeah
and people will notice it'll come out
he'll put
the name simon is up there now and he's
a guest judge guess where he is
guess where he's sitting where's he
sitting next to
are
you
nervous about it being part of it yes um
super excited listen i appreciate talent
uh talent simon as a talent of course
but as like a businessman you know he
built this empire which we are now a
part of which is you know this got
talent family it's a worldwide franchise
and we're part of it so i'm excited uh
to see this item and uh
well all i'm getting ready to do is do
this either like behind trish or in
front simon are you crazy simon are you
out of your mind that's all i'm that's
all i'm practicing oh tonight that's
what i'll be doing is i'll be sitting up
in my hotel room yeah just doing like
crunches but in a weird way just like
you can be like simon oh you're on your
mind yeah you gotta be crazy something
you want to put in fitness tuesday the
conscious that's right
um do you think he will appreciate the
talent in canada
no
yes
i was sweating there i was like
he thought perhaps we were being he did
say that see we're being a little nice
okay listen when we first started there
was it was a learning curve right we got
the new kitties that we had to deal with
yeah we mean to these kids they're so
cute we'll traumatize them for life um
but there was times also where we'd be
like so that's a no from us sorry and
we're like why didn't we say that
literally after everything
so there's no more stories now we don't
mess around and we say no we mean no
there you go see i'm practicing so he's
gonna love it i think he's gonna be
really excited about the talent right
listen he's gonna have a good time and
listen one thing that i will tell you is
that uh
him and how we are besties yes so
already like they they come with this
like this history you know i mean for
doing it so long and then it's like i
think this is whoever set that up like
it's going to be perfect like as i'm
looking at the names and how everything
is set up like that energy is going to
be crazy it's going to be a fun-filled
night for sure it's gonna be so fun so
excited and coming to an ending right
like you guys really got to know each
other as judges and friends and the crew
i mean yeah it's a bittersweet thing for
sure because it's like yeah we're like
the big moments culminated to this point
at the same time we say goodbye until
next season that is hey
hey are you confirming a season two is
that okay
i wish this is this is man this is
manifestation speaking it into the
universe yes so speaking of universe
overtaking blink if
all the way to be like guys that was
pretty cool right uh never gonna happen
again but i'm just here to say that you
guys suck so i'm hoping that he's here
because it actually went well yeah
because i'll tell you shout out to
everybody across canada because you know
we travel a lot especially the two of us
like we travel a lot and you what did
they say there was a uh
a little tagline they said like from
from nana's to nieces like yeah
everybody it's so crazy how
transgenerational the show is like you
know young kids are like cardi cardi
who's going to win i'm like i don't know
but you know but like little kids but
then literal also like everybody
grandmothers are like we watch every
week we're gonna watch so i mean it's
been an incredible incredible experience
and you know at the beginning people saw
like the different personalities they're
like how's it gonna matter these guys go
it's amazing though it's amazing amazing
chemistry congratulations to those of
you and this whole team and we can't
wait to see who the winner
you